hello and welcome to GameSpot daily
where we cover six news stories in 30
minutes or less or your pizza is free
I'm Gally no free pizza yeah and I'm
joined by Michael Hein we're not getting
pizza today though it's taco Thursday
here at CBS Interactive for some reason
taco day yeah talk today and it's
thirsty Thursdays - so we round the
world everywhere
it's the thirst of Thursdays here at
GameSpot and you know why that is
because our our first couple stories are
all oh the thirst is real the thirst is
real a yes fitting for Thursday Thursday
stories so the first one is one that I'm
personally very excited about let's
let's quench that thirst real quick all
right so there's a new Witcher 3 figure
it's a Geralt nendroid and it features
bathtub girls do you want you want
scroll down I do give our viewers a nice
little look at it so big Android fan I
don't a lot of non droids they're
obviously Japanese fully articulated
figures and they're often in a chibi
style and so this is Nendoroid girl and
he comes with other things not just the
bathtub so we can scroll through some of
these images he comes with both his
steel and silver swords so that's a cool
detail he's got some fire naturally Agni
if you will he got quite cards and there
he is and he has these cool veins Oh
cute and there he is
look he's got a little grimace yeah so
yeah so it's up for pre-order right now
on good smile comm make sure you go to
the English website and I have this
story on King spots so you can find the
page because sometimes it could be a
little hard on good smile um but he
costs around four thousand four thousand
eight hundred yen before tax but when i
pre-ordered him last night full
disclosure I already bought him he costs
$69 that's nice not a joke that's very
nice
so if you're interested yeah let's just
go back to that real fast the bathtub
one oh it's Geralt of Rivia
oh he's so cute yeah that's pretty
pretty dope I've seen seen uh
persona and Androids there's persona and
under a lot of nindroids are anime
characters I own most of the Pokemon
Nendoroids actually there's a Yukiko a
monkey one and there's also I've seen
Joker
Ming career for p5 those things are cute
those things are a lot of a lot of a lot
of good detailing them yeah that hitting
this off on a good note
yeah that makes me happy I'm very happy
I was very happy when I saw it it like
11:00 p.m. last night yeah cute little
figurines make me happy
anyway so on the but on the daddy train
just kidding just kidding just kidding
anyway depends if you're Diddy Kong then
yes this does have to do with your dad
mmm-hmm
Donkey Kong plays switch when he idles
in tropical freeze on switch that's what
so a lot of us a lot of us here at
GameSpot when we idle we play our swing
so yeah in duck Kong
Donkey Kong Country tropical freeze is
the full title I usually just say
tropical feet
freeze yeah I can't talk anyway the
Kong's place which games if you leave
them still for long enough and we have a
video of it and this credit goes to
GameXplain for this video yeah but if
you want to check out these idle
animations so different things happen
depending on who you have with you so if
you have DK and Diddy they play together
which is really cute
Dixie tries to take the controller and
cranky refuses to play like my dad too
old for this yeah he's so cute
yeah that's a door we got back to back
call he's now he's back to business he's
done back to back uh cute stories we got
here yeah we got the cutest of stories
the switch version of tropical freeze
also adds funky Kong as an easy mode so
he has infinite jumps and rolls and can
land on dangerous surfaces with his
surfboard as funky Kong is wont to do
whoo so yeah that game comes out May 4th
and you know it's not the only game that
has in-game switch playing in fact the
new Pokemon games have you have a switch
in your room because you know how you
like you said like an NES in your ass
nests in your room and then like
and 64 in your room in Pokemon the
latest ones have switches okay
so that's cool yeah Nintendo doing that
viral marketing gonna be playing this
gonna be playing a tropical freeze on
switch yeah I actually didn't get to
play it on Wii U and I did have a Wii U
I just didn't get around to it so thanks
for that you're welcome anyway um oh man
what a transition this this will be this
will be a story for that I've been
following and it's reached a conclusion
oh boy it has so we talked about Donkey
Kong now we're talking about the king of
Kong or Lee Mitchell the former king of
pop king of Kong or the ousted king of
Kong and I would say now so this story
comes from polygons as you can see white
so you're you've been following this
story walk me through what's happened so
far if I recall let me see if I recall
this correctly so well let's run through
what the news yeah so Twin Galaxies
trackers Tong galaxies tracks video game
world records and they have decided to
revoke Billy Mitchell's scores and ban
him from from participating further in
the high score in the race for high
score race yeah tracked by Twin Galaxies
let's read this quote I'll read this
quote it says mmm-hmm based on the
complete body of evidence presented in
this official dispute thread Twin
Galaxies administrative staff has
unanimously decided to remove all of
Billy and Mitchell's scores as well as
ban him from participating in our
competitive leaderboards they like
that's like very yeah shame on direct
yeah they're uh if you don't if you're
not familiar Billy Mitchell's like a
very he's an old-school very competitive
gamer and he had a high score and um
Donkey Kong which was it was it's been
superseded over time but so the thing
was is that people were looking at his
tapes and they said huh this doesn't
this doesn't seem like like original
because then Twin Galaxies only uses
like scores from the original cabinets
right if you use anything else then it's
not valid if you use an emulator it
doesn't count
yeah so they were looking at his footage
and saying like this these frames right
here
exactly line up with the original
cabinet yeah the question was like are
there skipped frames this is running
differently than the game originally
would and of course he's called he was
called the king of Kong because of the
documentary king of Kong we're watching
now as a trailer for that documentary so
yeah he was he was just accused of using
an emulated version for that million
point run and then his challenger Jeremy
young said the run was falsified and
passed off his gameplay from an original
arcade cabinet so I like the Challenger
was like uh-huh no yeah
there's some other stuff about he back
in I think February he came out and said
huh I don't know what name is or I never
used name in my life what his name stand
for is in my mind a child I just think
auntie which is not MAME is a way of two
people will get that joke emulating
video games like with the great I think
it has like a gray legal area but oh
yeah it's not like a true reproduction
of games like there's with the with the
nature of emulation there's gonna be
like things like skip frames or you can
even get even game game the game okay in
many ways but so that's why Tony Twin
Galaxies doesn't take emulation as true
gameplay so in February though Billy
Mitchell is like hey 20s has the tapes
if they don't have the tapes and I don't
know where they are and is on that the
main tapes or they're not named tapes
but what tapes I mean the normal tapes
by this this is a big story that kind of
blew up earlier this year and it's Billy
Mitchell is a figure of the past that is
somewhat relevant now that he has
completely ousted from the record books
now he can go back to focus focusing on
selling hot sauce and wearing American
flag ties as as you do um he so he was
best known for the DK score but his
pac-man score was also like all of his
scores were serving
Paquette score I want to talk about this
person because his name is so great
Steve Wiebe friend of the ship just
kidding we're all babies here yeah he is
now recognized as the only legitimate
million point scorer in Donkey Kong so
congratulations to Steve Wiebe on your
fantastic last name yeah and being the
only one to score a million points in
Donkey Kong it was documented in king of
Kong their supposed it rivalry but that
how many years later has been resolved
and we have a clear winner we have a new
king of Kong congratulations
Steve Wiebe Steve Wiebe the he should
just be the king of everything yeah
that's good I think I'll take that name
same we'll just go change our names we'd
be daily yep all right and then this is
probably the biggest story of the day
yeah it's our headline story actually
we're a battle royale daily pub Gees
latest update tweaks Miramar and the
blue circle of death or the blue zone
whatever you call it I just call it this
circle yeah the circle blue circle the
blue circle yeah there's there's plenty
of changes that have been made to it
that are now live on the actual game
client yes so a new server yeah
initially they were on the test server
and they've been pushed live to
everything so Miramar the desert map has
been tweaked in the north eastern and
northwestern portions of the map to make
them quote more appealing because you
know there's like nothing up in the
northwest yeah the military base is
pretty lit that's in the East that is in
the East whoops my bad I can't get my
directions right there's a lot going on
in the military base though and also
there are an oasis can now be found in
the north and while Alcantara village
has been added to the northwest so
there's a little bit more density yeah
which is nice because we've talked about
how this map kind of has these long
stretches of nothing yeah and not only
that is it's very hard to traverse you
know like in and around between towns
because there's so few roads and when
you do go off-roading
it's there's a lot of the buggies the
only one that could handle it yeah it's
pretty trashed like trying to try to get
across so they have added there's there
are additional roads and off-road paths
and car spawn locations
have also been added to those areas so
if you do get caught up in those areas
it's a little bit easier to get out
which is nice the delegate and then on
to the blue zone the delay time between
the blue zones or blue circles has been
decreased which gives you less time
between phases so I guess that's like
less waiting around and the amount of
damage taken from the 7th 8th and 9th
blue circles has also been increased yes
which was already freakin high if we
don't want hit kill sometimes yeah if
you get if you don't start running fast
enough out of that out of those last few
circles like you're done son yeah you
better get off your ass and now you're
hella done something yeah
yeah all in-game clothing spawns have
been removed so you're not gonna be like
picking up striped shirts for no damn
reason that is a relief that makes
looting such a pain in the ass I'm like
I don't want to look like a doofus I
have this cool jacket for a reason yeah
and all the other items like weapons
ammo and armor and all that good stuff
remains the same yep
which I wish they would just increase
the rate of some weapons but that's fine
yeah and then there's currently no
announce date for when oh wait no that's
wrong it has been rolled over into the
game oh yeah yeah
obviously these notes started yesterday
so that's why yeah things change
constants are always in flux here at
Battle Royale daily and then we have the
full patch notes on GameSpot or you can
also pull them up so you can just what
we have oh we are just from from pub pub
G himself I mean the PU himself yeah and
on the steam community page have
outlines the specific details of course
we're not going to read them all out
here for you but you can take a look at
it yeah but yeah like it's showing in
its this kind of small sorry about that
but it is it does show like the
different zones and things that were
added could you zoom in
can i zoom in I can if I can find the
plus button there it is the plus ultra
button there we go okay yeah so you can
check out 1 2 & 3 those zones have been
modified to be a little bit more
exciting I still I'm all about I'm all
about this you can't even see it on here
I'm all about the
the cool like beach strip oh yes it
calls again yeah it's like something
Delmar Delmar yeah it's been a really
long time since I got split up gene
because my PC is still not functional
Michael hi as we started talking about
this when we were starting the show back
when we were just piloting it still
haven't fixed your computer huh I still
haven't fixed my computer because
computer parts expensive they sure are
you know it's not an expensive sometimes
an Xbox one and miramar is also coming
to xbox one version of pub G I know E
which you know if you've played that
version you'll know it's it's it's it's
a whole other experience of jank it it
doesn't run well it does not as well say
the what I call it the mobile version
runs better yeah it does yeah I don't
know what's up with that
but you Xbox players out there will get
the map what is it in May they said next
month me so next month you finally get
another map on Xbox one and will tell us
if you like it once you do play it yeah
us PC gamers have been play I think we
may have talked about this earlier in
the week but we have played it for a
while on the the feelings towards the
the second map have we're like oh snap
is a new map this is dopest oh and then
it's like okay this actually isn't that
great I still like it very much
well I'm excited about those changes to
the map which I am actually not sure if
those changes are also being included in
the Xbox rollout so something to look
out for but I am excited to try them out
and see if they do make the map less of
a pain in the ass yeah speaking of pains
in the ass oh my gosh who's kidding just
kidding
I'm only love around here destiny choose
next expansion war mind gets a release
date so war mind is coming to PC Xbox
one and ps4 on May 8th which is very
soon it will send you to new places to
meet new heroes and battle new enemies I
want to remain optimistic about this did
not like curse of Osiris
yeah I remember you reviewed well Cali
over here has reviewed destiny - and the
curse of Osiris expansionpak so how
what's your what's your feeling on
destiny - in its current state um I just
I don't know they're not doing enough to
make it a sustainable like long-term
experience I I'm not the kind of person
who I didn't play destiny one like that
either
and back in the day I did review rise of
iron so I've been I've been in the
destiny game for a while
I think the shooting is impeccable I
think like of all the shooters I've
played this is my my favorite feel to
the weapons and and I love the mechanics
of this game and I just wish there they
did more with it I I don't know if a war
mind is gonna be like they're taking
King but we don't have a lot of info on
it right now there's gonna be new loot
and activities obviously yeah what sort
of activities I don't know cursive
Osiris activities where it's like I'll
do the same thing ten times and then
maybe you'll get to make a new weapon
nah I don't want to do that yeah so
Bungie will be revealing a more during a
live stream on April 24th which is 12
days from now oh my god yeah so they're
yeah like you said there are no real
details on what war mine will consist of
but you we will know quite soon yeah I
don't know if you mentioned earlier but
the release date is May yeah may 8th May
8th is also the kickoff for season 3 of
destiny - yes which adds seasonal
crucible rankings private matches vault
space equipped emotes more like more
equipped emotes exotic weapon master
works which is the thing I only did two
earlier that I didn't think was worth
doing and more coming this summer who I
you know the what made it all worth it
was when I got the spicy ramen emote the
one where you eat the bowl of ramen
that's the best emote therus really you
can see you grind it for a hundred hours
got the emote and then said yep it was a
whole worth it you know that's not and
that's pretty accurate to what I did the
last DLC cursor Osiris came out in
December like I said which May
me think that maybe warmind isn't well
you see the thing about Christmas iris
was it was very minimal and maybe wore
mind is the more substantial one but I
don't know if enough that time has
passed
I'm I have a lot of hesitation with this
so I'm interested to see what what
everybody thinks in the comments about
this if you still play destiny I mean a
resident destiny expert Eric Tay
around here doesn't even play destiny to
anymore yeah but I mean when you
consider well a lot of conversation is
like we put in 100 or so hours and did
the raid like a few times like I mean do
you want to live in that world
constantly even after doing all that
there is I mean if you've played a
hundred hours isn't that didn't you get
like as much as you could out of it like
shouldn't you why would you expect more
out of it unless like but then also you
have to take into account them account
the quality of those hundred hours right
and to be fair I mean I didn't like
curse of Osiris and but I really liked
the base game I thought destiny to have
such a great foundation for destiny I do
think they could do a lot with it I
think there was a lot that was improved
over destiny one as far as like making
it more accessible for all types of
players rather than just the most
hardcore having the best time like I
think there's a lot to do if you just
want to go around and shoot stuff which
is what I did for a lot of it and I did
enjoy that and it was fun and like I
said like there this is like a
mechanically like masterfully done game
I think as far as the shooting goes so I
mean do I hate destiny no but it would
take a lot to impress me I guess is what
I'm kind of get okay and we will find
out if we will be impressed on May 8th
we were when we when war mine does roll
through and also again like we said
April 24th there's going to be a Bungie
livestream to reveal what more war mine
will contain awesome and then finally we
talked about Geralt at the beginning of
this show and things come full circle so
remember how Garrett was announced for
still color e6 well we got another Soul
Calibur 6 character and an OG character
one that is not much of a surprise
coming to Soul Calibur considering that
he
probably probably one of the bigger
centerpieces its Siegfried ya sickly and
I like that Tamar's lead on this story
is Soul Calibur sadboy returns which I
appreciate
and so here's the quote would you like
to read the quote yeah sure I'll read
the quote after losing to Killick and
his comrades in the form of nightmare
Siegfried awoke in an unfamiliar place
and he is now unable to free himself
from the unforgiving memories of his
past or is his time spent has a curse
and swords puppet the memory of having
killed his own father is haunting him
his true nightmare has only just begun
full of regrets he is looking for
redemption and he desperately wants to
free himself from the curse it's Sora's
grasp yeah there's a lot going on with
him truly fitting for a sad boy there's
no release date for Soul Calibur sexy
yet so we don't know when we'll get our
hands on this but it is coming to Xbox
one ps4 and PC mm-hmm Soul Calibur 6
this year yes we'll be out this year wow
that's a big sword yeah Siegfried was
always one of the characters who are
more who has had a big sword and did
more heavy attacks so yeah little big
sword yeah don't we all regret things
especially for a sad boy
so what we all about out here yeah I've
played soul blade back in the day when I
was a little little dumbass kid and I
really look miss I miss weapon Fighters
yeah so we got the sixth Soul Calibur
which is the seventh in the Soul series
I suppose sure because soul blade and
then math is hard yeah alright well soul
edge was the arcade game and that soul
blade was the console version then we
got Soul Calibur up until the sixth one
which is coming up this year and
Siegfried is a staple of the franchise
and we're he's gonna be coming in so
about Soul Calibur 6 which is not much
of a surprise but it's good to know yep
alright so that was our sixth story oh
oh however six was
storia denoon but in other kind of like
random miscellaneous news of the day a
God of War ps4 review embargo lifted at
midnight so lots of reviews are up if
you're interested in God of War we have
our review here on games but we always
do reviews roundup if you're interested
in kind of the holistic approach of like
who who liked it generally everyone
people liked it yeah everyone liked it I
think across the board it's like between
if you're into if you're into review
scores about nine to ten yeah really
okay nine and ten high scores and then
obviously like um I think a lot of the
reviews are really long to largely
spoiler free so there's if you're if
you're not sold on the game if you're
like a got a war fan who's not sold or
if you've never played god of war and
you're not sure I think a lot of the
reviews will do a lot to convince you I
really enjoyed reading Peters review
here Peter Brown reviewed God of War for
us and I also got to play I mentioned
this yesterday is that I got to play a
little bit of God of War myself
pre-release it's the light isn't out yet
actually so we're still a week away from
the full release a little bit more than
a week away from the full release but
our review yeah forty really say it
wasn't Atreus at really at Reyes raise
it 420 where he raised it cuz he's a
child
yes yes took me a second we also have a
combat feature up specifically all
combat in that game I know that's a big
draw for god of war fans so check that
out I think Mike my already did that
Mike and Peter teamed up to bring you a
feature about god of War's combat system
because it is very different from
previous games if you don't already know
that mm-hmm and then lastly fortnight
was down but now it's back up and
therefore if you're watching live today
we'll be streaming that Erte will be
streaming that right after this so don't
go anywhere maybe refresh that page if
you're watching on Twitter YouTube we
will be live and if you're not watching
live that video will be on the YouTube
the YouTube the youtubes and onto it and
on the twitches the twitches yes yeah
for tonight has
that porta four thing where you can
throw essentially what's a grenade and
then it'll sprout up a prebuilt fort for
you which is like a sniper tower
I wonder if tazed gonna get his hands on
that like a prefab fort yeah it just
goes like yo that's how hard is it to
get that no I think I imagine be a rare
item that seems like a pretty convenient
item to have I haven't ran across the
Porta fort I haven't ever played for
tonight oh man you missed it you're not
one of the 45 50 million people who have
been playing for tonight
lucky you I'm just kidding four nights
ago four nights a great game
some some may say it's a somebody say
it's a great game in fact you did say ah
damn it I that I got got ya I got myself
Michael hi I'm here reviewed the battle
royale mode I did so and I believe you
did say it was great I did I said it was
great it's straight medicine yeah for
for all that you may not like about
fortnight you can't deny that it's an
incredibly well built game well-built
game though cuz you build things before
tonight alright goodbye bye bye Kelly
but anyway yeah we're gonna be streaming
some fortnight and you should check out
my review that I collabed with Nick
margarita on for video Marc's Nikki
Margie me and Nikki Martha spent a
weekend reviewing fortnight for y'all so
please check that out yeah cuz they were
here for most of the weekend I did hear
that he got pizza but you didn't oh that
was on a son you got a bone to pick with
somebody on that I think my pizza's free
I better be here eats it your pizza is
not free because we finished in under 30
minutes ah damn so I'm gonna keep
dragging this on psych anyway we could
we could wrap it up we could open up now
we want to thank Matt Padgett and Tony
Wilson for getting our rundown and notes
squared away this morning so we could
come in and do the news yeah
did we thank Emily cuz we should think
it we should always think Emily she got
me a cool mirror so I could do my makeup
in here oh yeah so we don't have to look
at the look at the live feed that we
have over here of ourselves convenient
and then
because he taught us how to go live
that's pretty cool yeah he makes sure
that we we don't screw anything up we
don't break anything generally just so
it's his fault if we do break the yeah I
can't blame table he's one of the best
boys here here a game we got a lot of
certified good boys all right I think
that's about it thank you for watching
and thank you for sticking around for
whatever the [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah we thank you
all for hanging out it's chill we just
want to talk about the news hopefully
you have a good time because we have a
good time
it will be here every day like we said
until we die so well every weekday so
we'll see you again tomorrow and we hope
you have a nice Thirsty Thursday mmm
it's a growl fro the stream with
fortnight with Eric day and we'll see
you tomorrow bye bye